[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello you are watching game sports play
for all charity stream is they who knows
time is meaningless is a flat circle and
trying to get any sort of grasp on it is
an act of madness I am tomorrow saying
joined by a game source very own kirtan
Davina hello Kay and then I have a trio
of amazing guests we have Sam Lake hi
Sam hello we have Bruckner we have
Brooke Maggs and then we have Mikael
Kathryn and hi did I pronounce your name
right I know it's beautiful thank you
thank you it's beautiful thank you
of course you know them as the minds
behind many games most recently control
but we're actually going to be talking a
lot about the things that you guys love
for background for people who don't know
or won't know is mix and I kind of
chatted at the Game Awards and the
interview was ostensibly about control
but quickly devolved into us talking
about Don through from the boreal valley
from dock so three and various other
things and it was a fantastic time and I
thought let's just get a bunch of folks
in you know Korea folks from remedy and
we'll do the same we'll just talk about
the things you love and maybe people can
get some insight into what inspires you
before we kick that off though I do want
to mention that we are doing the stream
in aid of raising money for two
incredibly important causes the first
being covered relief we are partnering
Direct Relief you can see the link on
the screen bit Oly /gs - co vid and then
the second cause being black lives
matter you can see the link on the
screen there bit o ly for /gs - BLM
please go to those links and donate
generously if you can all the money goes
directly to both causes and they're
super valuable if you're unable to
please share the links to around them
Twittersphere and Facebook where you can
is super super helpful to us
so I did say I was gonna start by asking
you what are the most impactful games in
your life are bit of an ambush question
that is a lot to deal with I'm gonna
start with I feel like McHale might know
his one already so I'm gonna start with
you what do you reckon we go okay so yes
normally I would say start control two
because it's a weird choice like you
know many people don't even remember
it's been a while but it was one of the
first kind of open well this game with
exploration you know awesome story
dynamic galaxy and different races
living and doing all kinds of different
things
well I'm thinking today is a special day
it is 20 years now exactly since Deus Ex
came out and Deus Ex it's I think a game
that changed how I looked at games
overall amazing immersive simulation and
I think it did a lot of things that I
just didn't know the games could do I
didn't know that that was allowed that
you can do things like that and that
sense of choice and complexity deep
storylines all the conspiracy stuff all
of that was right up my alley like
exciting kind of mysteries to be
resolved and you could develop your
character it had RPG elements and and so
on and that game man that was amazing
and there's this meme out there that I
think tells a lot about the game where
like when somebody mentions deus ex
somebody will reinstall it so i'm
expecting - figures right now starting
to reinstall that game did you have that
feeling where when you were playing the
game you're like I wonder if I can do
this and you give it a go and then
you're like oh my god I can do this like
I wonder if I can hack the computer and
then you go up to it and you're like no
way I can actually do that in this game
like that was my experience with that
like yeah it was so amazing like this
little thing that I did like you can
plant these bombs under the wall right
then I could jump on top of the bombs
and get to a place in a different way
that I know it wasn't kind of supposed
to do it but the game worked it wasn't
like it cost immediately a bug or a
problem the game was built with the
mindset that you know it's up to the
player to figure out like how do you
want to go about it and things just that
was crazy crazy at the time how how kind
of up on have you stuck with that kind
of type of game any of you guys like are
you still is the lineage of that are the
only games in the lineage of that Deus
Ex kind of that you still stick out to
you you know for a lot of people stuff
like you know dishonored and and that
kind of stuff is
yeah prayers I came to mind yeah pray
like is that something are those games
that you played and what did you think
of those what did you take away from
them so for me definitely I I loved
those type of games in massive Sims and
I loved spending time on them dishonored
absolutely fantastic game sequel as well
and I'm always excited to see what
arcane just next so what'd you think
about that kind of storytelling the the
kind of the immersive sim style is that
something that is interest you how do
you think like obviously we we don't
want to funnel everything into how how
did it inspire you but do you think Deus
Ex in a way has impacted the way you
tell stories I kind of get a feel like
in my house in a way I think yeah when
you look at control I mean there's a lot
of the lorentz stories are built into
the world and you actually have to you
know find them yourself and so on so
there's this kind of an embedded layer
of information things for you to
discover and find and realize hidden
truths and so on and Deus Ex definitely
was the game where it surfaced so
clearly the first time I played it and
and it's definitely inspired me on so
yeah to me it's fundamentally I guess
it's just basically demonstrated the
possibility that exists within games in
that sense of agency and that you can
choose to experience the story in a like
a different way or you can have an
impact to the story can make different
choices and
and so on and that's ultimately what
games are to me it's about the agency
that you have that sense of you know the
spotlight is on you like you are there
like it's it's up to you to figure out
how you're gonna go about it and that's
what makes it you know not passive but
interactive and many games before that
tended to be like this you know and I'm
you know generalizing obviously a lot
but still it felt like that at the time
the lot of games were just you know it's
a bunch of bad guys and go and calm them
down and move on to the next level and
and that was it like you just went on
this linear path and didn't really do my
should or even think about like what the
hell is going on why am I even doing
this stuff and there's there's of course
games that did amazing things before
that like Ultima Underworld you know the
90s and star control two absolutely
magnificent game that there was this
sense of choice that you could have in
Interpol and that what defines games to
me the sense of interactivity and some
people that definitely want to be able
to bring into the game started I create
interesting Brooke was it for you that
kind of what game do you think has had a
huge impact on you and also kind of
picking up where makes kind of drop
there they're like what what do you most
want from games what really sticks out
to you as invaluable game experience oh
my goodness
well I might start with the first thing
about the immersive seems I think so
having a think about and I think mine
was the most impactful in that genre was
Bioshock the first one which of course
came from System Shock but that was the
first time that I played a game that was
really well read in terms of philosophy
and how it was delivering this
commentary on society built on new ideas
and how it went horribly wrong like it
was as much of an intellectual
interrogation as it was a cool game with
powers and guns like it was super
interesting like in people have written
papers on you know what that game has
managed to do even with its storytelling
and you know you always remember the
would you kindly
trope that you know you and so I think
you know those games that and the other
one was fallout three that stuck with me
like when I opened I remember still
remember opening the vault and stepping
out into the wasteland for the first
time and just being like no it was
beautiful but in terms of the most
impactful game I am going to do the
nostalgia II sing and go back to some of
the first games I played and I think the
ones that have had the most impact is um
Tim Schafer's full-throttle and the
reason you're speaking my language
it is so slightly futuristic world of
biker gangs with political intrigue that
serious as much as it's fun and brutal
as much as it's heartwarming and it's
got a killer soundtrack and basically
you even get to like leap over a gorge
on your motorcycle it's it's super cool
but I think the one the thing that
stands out about that game was the
character Maureen Cooley like she was
one of the first I guess characters in a
game outside of Sonic the Hedgehog who
had an impact on me because she was real
and complicated and her and the main
character Ben strike up a friendship she
helps him fix his bike but then later
you realized that she's the daughter of
a young of the owner of a motorbike
company who was killed and so she's a
bit angry and kind of trying to work out
what this means and eventually has to
step up and take over her father's
legacy and she's a secondary character
in the game but she was funny but also
like had this no [ __ ] attitude and
like bounced off the main character
really well and I think Tim Schafer just
does funny in games and witty like like
some of his dialogue I still remember
and that's like since the nineties when
I played that I was you know pretty
young but
so into that game so yeah I could
probably go on about it for a while I
mean I could I could I could never stop
talking about
the sincerity and and also like comedy
in drama and complexity of summative
Schafer's writing especially in fandango
in full throttle but yeah so you're
speaking the full throttle like early
age for me I played it when I was very
young
who's gonna date myself I think it was
like seven seven ish and that happened
when I play that game but that was that
was like a turning point when I was
still a young lab that had no idea what
games were other than you know like
Sonic and Mario in that way and like
playing full throttle first time I was
like I'm like rolling this this this
like this narrative this experience and
like having stakin in in a different way
rather than going left and right it was
still in the real world like it was
still very it's kind of modern but still
a bit futuristic which I really enjoyed
and if I can have one more game thank
you
Sam and Max if you remember Sam & Max
hit the road which was n click adventure
yeah I know I know it's like it's it's
it's near and dear so it's good I mean
it was made like Steve Purcell like he's
he's like his mind just must be bonkers
because you're a group of freelance
police like I still remember the start
where there's a mad scientist
threatening to laser his lunch date
because she's trying to break up with
him and said oh look it's not working
out and he's just gone evil scientist on
her so sam and max turn up and diffused
the situation but leave her sitting
there and she's like so grateful but
she's like oh you know maybe you should
untie me and then the credits roll or
something it's just so funny and then
you go to a carnival of oddities there's
a comic book kind of sized ball of yarn
that you go to there's an alligator zoo
in Florida and the villain is a famous
country in western star who's being
cruel to his um the creatures that he's
been keeping in the carnival life and
it's just such an insane game but I
remember so much of it
I like the make
with with just talking about doing
cycles gonna make you reinstall it like
hearing you talk about sailing max let's
go do I do I own that yeah can i play
that right now some what game are you
gonna make the audience reinstall what
is your what is your favorite most
impactful game yeah I already told you
before we went liar I I'm really bad
picking favorites adventure games now
that we talk about them sam and max
definitely kind of fond memories day of
the tentacle yeah there is a lot of them
but but yeah I mean it's I want to go
back all the way kind of the the biggest
impact for me that that kind of multiple
times just blew my mind
you know Commodore 64 we go back and the
Ultima series for me was starting with
the first ultimate game that I played
was ultimate - and and and from then on
like you know it was just raising the
bar three four five and and it was like
yeah no graphics were obviously like 2d
stick figure thing but that didn't
matter at all like it was incredible
that there was this game that contained
the whole world you know you know you
you go around you visit cities you go
into dungeons and and there there is
this long plot that you follow that was
my first experience with a role-playing
game you know and and
yeah that that made a huge huge impact
to me I 10 years later I discovered
tabletop role-playing games and that
became a big part of my life
but yeah Ultima Ultima series was was a
big big thing for me and I was eagerly
waiting for the next one
always adventure games yes I do tend to
gravitate towards story and and you know
even even going back to you know text
adventures like you know talk or
Hitchhiker's Guide or things like that I
I did love them and and I am dating
myself as an old man going back to that
time later you know half-life was a big
thing half-life 2 the episodes very
impactful ones System Shock yeah that
was a very very cool game and Bioshock
obviously a lot of great games one of
the things I'm interested in is like how
much do you these games like do you feel
like they are they I'm trying to figure
out the best way to phrase this but like
I feel like I can better explain why I'm
thinking by showing this situation I
have like when I'm I'm the oldest of
four and my two younger brothers are
into games and when they were coming up
with game coming up with games and kind
of figuring out what to play the stuff
I'd point them to is this stuff that had
impact on me like so there were plenty
of stories games being stories being
told in games that were contemporary and
probably better but I always told my
younger brother hey you need to play
Metal Gear Solid because that is the
story that's important like how much
does that happen to you like you know
when you're thinking about when someone
asks for a recommendation like hey I
want to learn about how to make a you
know write a good story how often are
you like oh you should play ultimate or
you should go back to and they all
I guess I guess the question is how
important or how necessary do you think
it is for people to really dig into the
history of the games that have come and
gone and find those seeds that have you
know given birth to the modern day of
you know gaming like should people go
back and play Deus Ex if they're kind of
and when all they know is dishonored and
pray and same for like you know if you
if you you know all you know is Walking
Dead should you go back to full throttle
etc that's a good question I might have
a somewhat controversial opinion on that
I I don't think there is I I wouldn't
want them silly people to look back i I
like looking forward and I think I do
think the games were better than what
they were in the past yes I've said it
out loud there's gonna be a lot of
people hating me now but I I generally
do believe that there's you know sure
like you know going back and playing
Deus Ex is is the thing and I rarely
read books twice I really watch the team
same TV show twice I don't watch movies
again once I've seen it that's it like
you know I have the experience there's
no need for me to go back I want new
experiences and with games interestingly
Deus Ex is the exception I did that like
maybe for 10 years where you know every
year like yep now it's time to replay it
again and and you know I did and it was
strange and every time I found something
new and different and I didn't expect
but still I I'm not on no static person
personally I don't I don't think things
were better in the past I think there's
things that you know we should learn
from there and and yeah I mean you know
I have I have kids and I'm thinking
about like should I show you know the
games a dad like back in the day and so
but always hold up you know I had the
experience lately of showing a friend an
old game that I absolutely loved and
unlike this is not going well
definitely straight away they're very
much better and it's hard
to capture what that game was like at
the time compared to everything else
exactly
there's a point in time where that kind
of can't replicate that certain games
have surprised me in terms of like I
struggle because like I'm a huge resin
evil fan and as I mentioned like Rin
Fandango and those are burdened with
tank controls and fixed camera angles
and things that are so alien and weird
to any anybody who's in the gaming now
didn't understand it then and someone
recently I was trying to like well
should I go back and play resin evil one
because it's a masterpiece and design
and like that I have all these
allegories from self being a puzzle and
all these things and then even when you
suggest a remake there wasn't remake
it's like it's still like it's well you
doesn't got a deal with it but then in
certain cases certain games I think have
a certain like shocked me and how
they've aged argues like half-life like
going back and playing half-life 1 I'm
surprised like going back this still
feels good like this still controls
really well even going back i didn't
played like the Gears of War series
until very very recently in my life
because of that reasons like people like
oh you should experience that you know
and I remember going back and playing
gears one and being shocked that that's
control why is it still like holds up
there still merit in that so certainly
you know two different spectrums among
on that but if it's someone who hasn't
played many games before and they're
like just recommend me a game what
should I get into I usually ask if you
follow up questions and suggest
something a bit more out there Ellie I
guess or something that might suit them
because I guess it's kind of like if
someone says I want to get into reading
you don't toss them war and peace or
ulysses necessarily Hundred Years of
Solitude
seems like you definitely does you like
you would Sam yeah I definitely would
throw so many blood-borne if they do
ever played a game before really isn't
the one that should experience it yeah
that's where I would go like I actually
feel a bit that like nobody's asked for
me really like what games to play but I
would go you me like Dark Souls blood
boy
yes before we launch into the next
question I just want to remind folks
that we are raising money for black
lives matter and covertly if you can see
both links at the bottom the screen is
paper ly and then for slash ether GS -
BLM OGS - co vid please donate
generously if you can we've had a
donation from Carolina Safari and we
donated towards black lives matter thank
you so much
someone mentioned you guys mentioned
half-life and so I'm gonna take us in a
bit of a tangent have you seen the
series half-life of ER but the AI is
self-aware this is incredible so like
maybe I'll somehow come figure a figure
our way to turning this into a question
something around like experiencing old
games in new ways but so this is a a
series that's done by someone called Ray
Wayne radio TV where it's half-life of
ER but every character is played by a
friend of his and they are trying to
inhabit that character but inevitably it
just all goes wrong so the first thing
that happens is there's a a god who just
for some reason decides to be obsessed
with Gordon Freeman showing him his
passport so at every turn he's like I
need to see her passport and Gordon's
like I just need to get into the lab and
do this experiment but this guy is
hounding him the entire time about
showing him is possible and they go on
this like I think it's like three
seasons worth it's like five episodes
each but it's like hours and hours and
hours of this journey where they just go
across the entire game with that
character and a couple of the scientists
and they all have their own unique
personality one of them is just like
seems to be unkillable for some reason
the other one is really obsessed with
soda pop and it's absolutely fascinating
but my thought is like if this is the
first time you see half-life imagine
what you must think about the rest of
this franchise and kind of like so the
question that the recommendation is if
you haven't seen it watch the series
because it's absolutely phenomenal and
so so there's like you'll see like memes
of the god in blue from half-life with
his like hand outs
saying show me your passport it comes
from this and then the other thing is
like how do you feel about kind of do
you experience old games through the
eyes of other people like are you are
you going looking searching out like
people experiencing Dark Souls for the
first time or someone you know playing
Ultima for the first time just to see
what their experience is like because I
know that's something I do I found like
there's this someone called Kay plays I
think her name's was but she was like
this incredibly soft-spoken lady who
played Dark Souls for the first time and
her first video was maybe 30 minutes and
it was like just walking through a door
but it was fascinating it was absolutely
fascinating so do you do that a lot or
is there something that you kind of once
you've experienced the game you're kind
of done with it forever
mm-hmm I do believe that it is an
interesting question overall like you
know when when when you talk with
like-minded people you kind of want to
hear about types of games do they play
because it tells something of that
person like what type of games they do
like to play and and definitely then the
perspective that they have into into
those experience there's definitely I
think something worth discussing
absolutely and especially with games
that are in nature kind of impenetrable
like that they are complex nuanced can
be experienced in multiple different
ways as I do believe Dark Souls could be
experienced I would love to watch you
know a person's never played video games
play Dark Souls and I just see so see
what happens is there's something
interesting there because even as a kind
of a game developer we we get jaded we
we kind of play certain types of games
that we placed so much that we're so
kind of used to certain conventions when
we when we said season and things we
already know what they are but seeing a
person who starts from like scratch like
they they try to understand the visual
language that exists within those worlds
like can i they are looking at the door
and I assume that it can be opened up
that's not necessarily something you can
do in every game and then there
used by what the limitations are and I
know I find it always interesting and
valuable and I think it also allows us
to be better as game developers when we
we understand the human psyche in in a
better way also people who are let's say
new to games have a preconceived idea of
what they are so sometimes I will
recommend games that are very much not
in line with that like I might recommend
something like journey for example like
that game is usually the game that I
recommend to someone who's never played
games before because not only is it
incredible in terms of its storytelling
but it's also not super demanding in
terms of and nor is it combative like I
think an element of stress that you've
described Dark Souls that people kind of
worry that they're not playing it
correctly and then they worry about the
stress and like Oh videogames you kill
people right and they will also kill me
right you wreck them into something like
that then they're like ah okay so this
is how to move and jump and explore and
do things and then you kind of work your
way into other games as well or at least
that's how I've sort of done it or I've
recommended some really nice like indie
darling mobile games or things that kind
of a shorter tighter experiences so then
people like well I played a game and
they kind of get some confidence then
and they're like I can do this game
thing and you're like alright journeys
great so such an elegant game and yeah
it's it's it's interesting it's like a
complex package and so on it's yeah it's
it's fun to see people play like when
they haven't done it before
there's the there is a bit of a shame
kind of what you mentioned broke where
people who are new to playing games they
immediately think that is some kind of a
competition like you know I have
to succeed in this I have to do well
like as if there is somebody else kind
of badly anything like how well are you
doing I'm sure okay there are games of
course it gives you a literally like
this is how well you did like it's your
score but still the feeling that there's
some kind of external pressure around
you and and there's a bit of a shame
because I would love people to be able
to watch games in the same way as movies
and books and so it is something it can
jump into it to me what makes games fun
is is about the immersion that I jump in
this world and and it's my place it's my
little bubble that I go into and and
it's up to me to decide what to do so so
I'd feel it is a bit of a shame when I
see people feel like oh it's some kind
of a competition or they need to fulfill
certain kind of external expectations
that's somehow exist around I don't
think that's there's also different ways
like games are a bit more complex
because there's different ways to engage
in a game there's sort of one way to
watch a movie and you know you sit down
and you watch it but with a game it's
like we'll do you prefer strategy or do
you prefer stealth and survival or do
you prefer to garden you know do you
prefer to do you know civilization and
do political intrigue and you know work
out how to run the world and things like
that so I think the first step to is
getting people who don't necessarily
play games a lot to understand that
there are many types of clay and this is
a medium that doesn't have to exclude
that because they don't like a lot if
the I guess more popular styles of play
like I mean I don't mind combat in games
I rather enjoy it sometimes but it's
true you just don't want that or they
want something else or yeah I do believe
I do believe that there is not a single
person on the planet who wouldn't be
able to enjoy a game out there I think
there is a game for everybody it's also
amazingly complex wide spectrum of
experiences we even mentioned like Dark
Souls and journey
those are very very different type games
and and I I can't imagine that there
wouldn't be a game for everybody out
even the most you know person who feels
like I've never played games or feels
that anxiety or pressure or just pure
this interest to us games and yes
shocking there are people like that as
well and but I do believe that it's just
to find the right game to show them and
I believe they would be hooked there's
something magical about the games that
III think is is I honestly haven't seen
in in books and other mediums so some
you yo we've got on one side we've got
Brooke talking about journey and then
we've got makes talking about Dark Souls
we've got both ends of the spectrum on
the recommendation there what would you
recommend to someone who asked you what
games should I play see if you can get
it somewhere in the middle so we have a
nice like equilibrium but I won't force
you into that Ultima where would Altima
feel on that
yeah yeah I guess Ultima would require
you know I you know as a young kid
playing that you know funny example of
not understanding anything about the
game was that a couple of years older
you know actually a big brother of a
good friend of mine was watching me play
Ultima too you know and I was quite far
in it and and he was wondering why it
takes me so long to kill an enemy and
and I was going like well I have the
best weapons and and then he checks out
and I have not known how to equip the
weapon I'm playing through the whole
game barehanded thinking that well yeah
yeah this is how you play
so so obviously you know it's and and
backed in you know as as you know it I
didn't apply it was a pirated game and
and as a young kid I didn't even
understand you know the concept until
later now I wish you had played through
the entire game just without ever
equipment because doesn't be so badass I
think your intention here was to talk
about how you didn't understand games
but what you've actually done is proved
that you'll probably the most hardcore
game of every game just with your fists
no weapons no armor but I guess yeah I
was just thinking about the Dark Souls
thing that you mentioned I would
recommend her following on from my
half-life recommendation the YouTube
channel Kay plays she's the Dark Souls
player that I mentioned earlier and I
think for people like who loves the
souls franchise they yearn for that
first time experience again like they
wish they could capture those moments
again and I can confidently say like
when I watched her play it reminded me
of how I felt because she was interested
in the things that most gamers aren't
interested in like you kind of off with
enough language and like experience and
time in gaming you have a tunnel vision
you know your objective you know you
need to get the thing you just start
running she starts off by like walking
out and noticing like a texture on a
wall and being like wow look at this
texture and it's so nice and like she'll
look at a sunset for ages or the first
thing she does is I think she's one of
the few people I've ever seen that
immediately got an item and looked for
an item description I was like what is
this thing and she like meticulously
reads it and makes like methodical
assessments of what it is and then
starts joining the dots herself it's in
my mind it's a completely blind and at
the same time she's contending with how
to use a controller properly but she's
she's not super literate but like I
think if the from software team were
watching it I think they would say this
is the perfect Dark Souls playthrough
like it's a
it captures everything it does wonderful
apps like I have to see it myself
I had no idea it's it's so good and the
comments are always like I've been
watching Dark Souls you know videos for
years and this is the first time I've
seen someone approach it in the way you
do and it's because she doesn't approach
it from the mindset of a gamer she
almost has like an archaeologist
approach to it where she's trying to
figure out the world and how it all fits
together and and like some of the videos
are 8 minutes of her trying to get up
some stairs and there's an enemy in the
way but like it's it's legitimately like
fascinating because she's like coming at
it from a very calm and like if Ally
waiting for the process in trying to
figure out why the enemy is attacking
her and creating these stories yeah it's
it's it's really fascinating but it is
it is really really easy to lose that
magic to see kind of you know behind the
scene and understand how its build and
and with that you are kind of already
out of the experience in a way yeah it's
like I'm playing through the Last of Us
right now and I have to remind myself
not to autopilot that game because
there's so much tiny effort that has
gone into creating that world that I'm
just kind of glossing by sometimes
things look so good
and so realistic that they become normal
like you throw a brick through a window
and you're like okay sure moving on but
then you think about your like the way
it shattered is like real and it sounded
real and it looked real and it had an
impact on the world around me people
heard that so it's like that that gamer
autopilot is something that I'm trying
to be aware of and I wonder like how
much do you think about that when you're
designing games like control like we
don't want to specifically a lot of your
games are like designed to in a way that
they kind of almost shocked you outfit
with things like how much do you think
about game or autopilot so I need to
kind of odd plane The Last of Us as well
right now I'm a amazing game and what's
beautiful about it is that they take
simple intuitive things and make that
the gameplay like those you know how you
try to kind of
the generators and so on sounds boring
and mundane but they manage to make it
exciting and you have to actually think
about all traduced through the window go
to the other side and and I'll make this
a thing that I can use to to climb up
onto something so they kind of size that
this really complex puzzle world that we
have created and in many games out there
where there are like a lot of
supernatural or complicated elements and
they they take electric wire and make
that a huge part of the game and I'm
just a technological marvel it's just
crazy how well made that game is you can
just holding the even just holding the
wires in the ropes like just like in
here when you're bringing them in and
you're wheeling them into your hands I'm
just like yeah adds up it feels like you
are there in the moment doing these type
of things and and it's it's it doesn't
feel mundane at all ever because somehow
they managed to make it very I don't
know there's this presence with
everything that you do that comes across
through the screen when you play the
game and little things that would be
things that you could just bypass or not
care about at all in any other game you
don't and last of us because there is
that great amount of care that's been
put into every aspect of the game but
yeah there's definitely a danger of
autopilot II and and I try to fight that
personally it's it's something that I'm
very aware of us as a game designer III
might sometimes kind of assume too much
and then kind of just rush forward and I
don't like playing personal games like
that I want to I want always to try to
kind of catch that wonder and and they
the intent of the game like you know
this is this is you know try to discover
like what is the experience that you're
supposed to have but at the same time
you want to of course test it and try
different things out and you know
discover that yourself so it is it is a
complex problem though and and what
matters most is the of course the amount
of experience and so on and and yes game
developers we we easily get we easily
kind of go into that mode especially
because we you know when we test our own
games and so we tend to go into that
mindset and that's why it's also really
fantastic to see people brave your game
for the first time he always like
surprised like what okay they played
like that and then you tried to learn
from that hmm Brooker's what's your
experience been like with gamer
autopilot as we've coined it now I've
been I've been similarly trying not to
autopilot the last of us but actually I
have been playing it very like I've been
devouring it but I have also just done
things like taking a photo of what it
looks like when you turn your flashlight
on am a wet road work sign and turn it
off again because it looks incredible
like the lighting on the surface of a
roadside like I've actually noticed that
in this game and like you walk into a
apartment and there's plants and you can
see someone's been growing tomatoes in
there and you're like what's going on in
this there's a lot of environment tool
storytelling to pick up on and also I
think what I like about the game too is
that it leaves you enough space to look
for that stuff and it also leaves you
enough space to get into the characters
like and it doesn't it's not super
breakneck action paced all the time like
and it's very considered when it puts
you in combat and when you're exploring
and it signals that very well without
being very gamey about it like if that
makes sense and that's a kind of thing
that I would I guess notices a developer
but and when I speak to other developer
friends when they talk about games I'll
be like oh yeah so I went through the
third combat encounter and then when I
came around and they use a lot of like I
got stuck in an animation loop so then
you know it kills me so the next time I
didn't and you're just like but people
when you talk to people who are not I
guess makers of the game like Sam was
saying you know that the curtain hasn't
been lifted then they can either not see
how detailed that environment is or you
know completely appreciate walking up
some stairs or you know looking at a
sunset for such a long time became like
a little game for me almost where I kind
of just check like I'm wondering if they
have
and yep they are like crazy there's like
you're inside and there's a campfire I
look up I look at the roof and see if
there's kind of a black like from from
at of course it has like the attention
to detail is is crazy and then I just
got to say like add what Brooke
mentioned I think the Last of Us is like
a master class in pacing like how well
it's organized and structured there's
always a good kind of chunk of time
spent in different type of activities
and and yes there are dark and tough
moment but it always leads to this other
kind of a feeling that there's this
sense of variation this emotional
rollercoaster do you go through and
there's enough like lull and kind of a
peaceful moments and of course then
interrupted with crazy violence and and
so on but it's such a well-made game Sam
what are your experiences with either
gamer autopilot or the idea of kind of
looking behind the curtain is that
something that you you're you do a lot
is there something that you try and
avoid I mean it's it is difficult to
avoid chumpy to last of us have managed
to avoid spoilers have not played it yet
summer vacation is just around the
corner I mean like you know then there
is proper time so we're waiting just a
bit for that yeah it's you know as a
game maker you know you you kind of need
to look at games from that perspective
to learn so it is kind of a facial thing
that you need to do the wonderful
feeling is when you forget when when
when you are playing something and you
realize that you have not been thinking
about that but I I don't know I mean
honestly you know for people who play a
lot and and and there is that kind of a
autopilot thing I wouldn't say that
that's a
somehow faulty way of experiencing
something you know that there are
different ways of experiencing it and
and you know none of them is wrong you
know if you want to focus on kind of a
more hardcore experience and just go
about it that's great as well of course
so so and and I I don't know I mean it
does go across all mediums you know when
you are watching a certain kind of a
genre movie say you know you can be a
bit jaded having seen a lot of movies
and and you know start expecting certain
plot twists or or you know end up not
enjoying because you are cynical and and
and you you kind of are criticizing
certain maybe slightly awkward elements
in it
that's one wonderful thing I feel having
kids and and experiencing you know
certain like bead game so big movies or
or anything experiencing with a young
person who is just eyes wide with Wonder
and and you just know that well if I was
watching this movie on my own or with my
friends I would be a lot more critical
toward it but then suddenly with
somebody who is going next to you just
oh then you can't help but be infected
with that you know sense of wonder and
suddenly going that's wonderful yeah
that's so true no I've kind of had that
experience now with breath of wild so I
haven't I started playing the game like
two years ago and I got quite far along
got like two of the divine peace taken
over but I never really finished it and
I started playing it again now my
I think a month ago I saw the same thing
yeah I met with kids Oh as well a child
that may start taking a cat but there's
this like moment where I start to play
the game because it's a bit too complex
for my kids cell but there was something
enchanting about that game when they saw
it and that they saw this world filled
with colors and different things
happening and they have like loads of
questions and so on and and the shaded
side of me that sometimes is there is
like that's just melted away and and
kind of see it together with the kids
this experience in this kind of a
different light and then of course I
kind of play along with like let's go
and watch like what's behind that hill
and you start to roleplay like almost as
a kid yourself and when you jump into
that world and it's been tons of fun to
to replay that game in that kind of I
want to kind of stick on that idea of
showing someone something and seeing
that response but before we do that I'm
gonna take the opportunity to remind
folks that we are donating money in
service or blacklivesmatter you can see
the link on the screen there and corvid
relief the money toward kobe relief goes
to health care workers on the front
lines of battling it we've had a few
donations call Henry donate $25 to buy
clothes man thank you so much
Nawaz Iqbal the frequent donor has given
ten dollars towards Kobe relief Eric
Taylor our very own Eric Terry who you
might remember the voice of God 35
dollars her towards covered relief and
then Craig Gilmore good friend of ours
$20 and he said long live K plays so I
want to ask the question do you remember
the loss or do you remember is a
specific memory of something or you're
proud of something that you showed
someone else and had them kind of be in
awe of or or had had your what you
wanted them to feel from it reciprocated
so for me is this movie called
confessions have you heard of it so it's
a Japanese thriller movie and when I
explain the plot very briefly it's gonna
sound a bit messed up but that's kind of
why it's the thing that
is so it's in Japan it's called Kohaku
and it's the story of it is there's a
teacher in Japan she has a class full of
students some of them are unruly they're
kids
in Japan there's a law which means if
you commit a crime before a certain age
you are not tried you basically you
cannot be convicted for it
it doesn't matter what the crime is
including murder so one day she brings
the teacher brings her daughter to
school her daughter is killed
unfortunately the teacher some realizes
that one of the students two of the
students in her class is responsible for
that murder obviously she the murder
will not be pursued while she does is
during the daily Japanese tradition of
like handing out juice boxes
she infects two of those with HIV
positive blood and then ensures that
their kids that she is are responsible
drink those and then tells them that has
happened and then the rest of the movie
is about the impact that has on their
psyche and then the impact it has on the
class around them and how they unravel
as people it's an absolutely fascinating
and bizarre movie and whenever I show it
to people I'm like you're in for a ride
stick with it you're gonna feel
uncomfortable but it goes places and
every time I've showed them people this
movie it's ended with them like jaw open
on the floor and I get a small kind of
russia' of seeing that happen and one I
think you should watch that movie
because it's incredible but yeah has
there been something that you've kind of
shown to someone else or recommended to
someone else and they've come back to
you and been like that was fantastic and
it's changed the way I sees him or like
had the experience that you wanted them
to have if so do you remember the story
and do you remember what it was there's
no big story but the movie that was kind
of like that for me was
primer which is this kind of a time
travel movie that is almost like a
puzzle in itself and if you really pay
attention you see how it all comes
together and I was so excited to show it
to a bunch of friends and they hated it
was like this gibberish it doesn't make
any sense at all so that was the story
they didn't say it like I did yes oh
well you try again give them something
yeah
broke me a mint that's telling I that's
telling you mixed to your your picks you
have a very specific idea of what's
brilliant and maybe you know you're the
one who sees it that way
that's really what's what's that's the
merit I hope so well this is tough I
think throughout my life there have been
those things where I've gotten obsessed
over and then just insisted there
everyone see these things and they've
ranged anywhere from stage plays to
books to movies or games really
depending on what I'm interpreting which
is probably a bit of an indication
what's going on like that I'm fascinated
with the creator at the time so examples
include I guess The Handmaid's Tale is
one which again is probably along the
lines of grim recommendations but um
like I think a lot of people sort of
wanted to resist seeing that because it
was too hard to watch or and I just sort
of said yes but it's kind of worth doing
that work don't you think you know it's
kind of work worth watching that I mean
obviously there's a certain amount of
content that we can all sort of deal
with and people can obviously make smart
choices about that but that was one but
then sometimes I know that my tastes can
be a bit niche so I try not to force
things on people but another one more
recently is Hannah Gatsby stand-up
comedy on Netflix which like comes off
as comedy but it's actually very
razor-sharp commentary and social
political commentaries
so I always say if you want to see a
cool Australian comedian go listen to
Hanna Gatsby and then people go that was
not what I expected I'm like I know
right so that's one that I just raved to
everyone about more recently on Netflix
and then Chuck Palahniuk books I can't
say his name correctly at this moment
but Fight Club whenever someone says to
me I liked the movie I said well you
should read the book you know I think
the book kind of really changed for me
what like voice is and can do with
characters in fiction like the way that
book is written is quite good and the
movie holds up as a really decent movie
in and of itself and then he also wrote
another book called invisible monsters
and where Fight Club is very hyper
masculine invisible monsters kind of
goes the other way and so I kind of
recommend those books in tandem and then
after that you'll be like what is this I
don't know what I'm reading so but that
goes back to the heart of what you were
saying about things that have been it
had an impact on us they haven't
necessarily always been enjoyable every
second when you're watching them but
you're like oh my god like it makes you
think and stays with you for a while and
I guess they're often the things that we
like to recommend but having said that
you know I also recommend things just
because I think someone will enjoy it
and get a laugh so yeah that's my take
Sam is there anything that you've kind
of given the gift of to anyone else
and recommend it and and they've
actually liked it or even you know not
likely now that makes us introduce that
precedent I tend not to force things
upon people like I mean if if something
comes up that is close to something that
I have loved and for sure I will
recommend these other things if they are
not familiar with them
I mean prove what you were saying about
read the book
you know that's that's usually a really
good recommendation I'm a big fan of
movies overall but usually if it's based
on a book read the book if you like the
movie read the book it's it is like when
you come to it after reading a book even
if it's a really good movie usually my
experience is that I feel that the book
was better you know very few exceptions
yeah I actually ask the exception of
that because there's been one kid maybe
like one or two cases where I find that
I've watched a movie that was based off
of a book and then I went to go read the
book it had for example the movie Drive
I was obsessed with I am obsessed with
movie Drive but I often forget that was
based off of eight of like a very more I
mean how do I put it like
genre focused crime noir book and I do
not like that book but I loved the film
but did the drive as a movie is like in
and of itself is no Nicholas Winton
Griffin particular lasting thing that
said is there any is there an exception
of those where you we think the movie
where you saw a movie they went back and
maybe wasn't the same examples where
where I have not purposefully not gone
and read the book at all after seeing a
movie or a show I did do that you know
with Game of Thrones as an example you
know I I was very much into fantasy
growing up discovering a lot of the
rings and and reading tones of fantasy
books for many many years until at some
point it's just started to feel like ya
know something something else and and
for years and years I I didn't really
enjoy anything you know in in fantasy
until then Game of Thrones came out and
started watching it and I was like well
okay this now is something different it
breaks the kind of the formula that is
so very familiar and and I didn't know
what's gonna happen to the characters
you know the early seasons especially
and and you know was really really
engaged with that and and happy that now
I can once again enjoy fantasy where I
just felt for years that I can't because
just overdose Tony and I also also
decided at that point that I'm not gonna
go and read the books that for me this
is now a show and and I'm very much
enjoying the show I don't need to read
the book I I can read other books so
maybe as a as a different kind of a
thing but but you know going back to as
a parent I mean there is a lot of joy
into your kids are growing up and and
you know when they are at the right age
you can introduce something to them that
that you know was wonderful when you
were growing up like like say reading
law you know first Hobbit and The Lord
of the Rings as a bedtime story you know
the whole thing true and you know seeing
the reaction and and and you know having
that captured audience eagerly waiting
what happens next
yeah Sam I do need to mention shining
space or they say right you know yeah
obvious ones like I I saw the movies and
then I actually went to read the books
and then I was like yeah I think I'm
Sam's bro up the Game of Thrones thing
and I would be remiss not to
dresser or at least get the the take of
people who are clearly fans or and also
who work in creating interesting
narratives and characters and that kind
of stuff what did you think of the
ending of Game of Thrones it's a trap I
mean honestly I feel that I love to talk
about things that I love and and
certainly there is value in in kind of
deconstructing something that didn't
work or or but but at the same time
there is so much content out there then
rather than you know beyond maybe trying
to learn from something that didn't work
the value of you know talking about it
and saying negative things I I don't see
the value of it worth of it and and if
there is one thing in this life that we
don't have a lot is time time is always
running out so spending time on you know
that is it doesn't doesn't be productive
or valuable to me but since you asked
and and here we are talking about it I I
was disappointed I I was such a big fan
of the early seasons but but that the
biggest problem to me was that where I
found huge joy in the early seasons as I
said having grown fed up with the
formula you know all this kind of a you
know first loving it then overdosing it
and getting bored with it and not
enjoying it and then finding Game of
Thrones
so clearly Prague get you know now
suddenly the hero might not survive
no the hero didn't survive I was rooting
on them and you know being being riveted
and excited about it and then towards
the end it did go back very very much
into that formula at least that's how it
felt to me so that was just like like I
lost the excitement at at some point
kind of the couple of last season's at
the same time you know looking at it as
a whole I think it was phenomenal and
and and a huge great achievement and and
and somehow I to me Game of Thrones was
a really really strong example of just
the kind of the scope of how things that
we had we we've grown used to seeing in
big movies suddenly being part of an
episodic format and and that's where the
world we live in now we're where I feel
that series and shows have a lot of
wonderful wonderful art and and
experimental things happening so one of
the things I wanted to kind of pick up
on there is so we used to do a weekly
Game of Thrones show on GameSpot so I
was very invested in Game of Thrones and
like you guys or like Sam specifically
agencies said it is I was disappointed
with the ending and it made me think
about how the impacts of impact of an
ending in retrospect like we have we
seem to be in it happened the other big
example of it is Mass Effect the third
Mass Effect the first three month of
Mass Effect's in my mind are some of the
strongest
storytelling and characterization in any
form of media and then the very final
moments relatively speaking a couple of
hours sure they didn't achieve or hit
the bar that maybe the rest of it was or
didn't wrap up in a way that everyone
thought or wanted it to do but we have a
kind of culture of we write off the
entire thing based on the ending of the
thing and I want to know what your
perspective is on that and do you think
that's a fair thing to do as people who
have to write stories from start to
finish and end them like how difficult
is that they do and how valid is that an
approach it's it's interesting that that
you say it kind of like wrong kind of an
ending can go back and and poison all
the enjoyment in him in a thing it's
it's an interesting psychological thing
endings are hugely important yeah and as
from from story perspective i I I do
often think about the ending almost as
the first thing you know and I know that
different creators see it in in
different way for me ending comes pretty
early I mean in in thinking about the
story and and and then you know a lot of
the things along the way is about the
end already setting setting things up
for it
yeah it's please it's interesting it's
it's also like going back to shows and
series overall it is something that you
know in in TV especially it's kind of a
has been a problematic thing that that
it's clear that many traditional shows
didn't know when they are going to end
and pencil
they do and and and you know the ending
isn't given a fair amount of preparation
and thought I'll agree that from from a
perspective of the ending kind of
reveals the true character of the
substance of that entire package in a
way and I do think that it happened a
bit and games I feel exactly like Sam
where there was this in a kind of feel
and I read the first three books and was
very excited about them because I also
felt like they kind of rediscovered the
chandre and did the unexpected and
that's what made it interesting and
exciting you want to see what happens
next because it felt like everything is
at stake right so that was the other day
sold or George sold in the first three
books but it kind of is it feels very
unfair to say it out loud like this but
I do feel like Game of Thrones ending
kind of ruins the beginning because
there's this feeling of it revealing its
true colors in a way okay actually it's
not about you know subverting those
expectations that we might have as you
know viewers anymore it is now a story
of unlikely heroes right like the
underdog that's what it became to me at
the end instead of being this greedy
complex realistic world where anything
can happen and still there is this kind
of a good story arc behind all of it
that kind of keeps you engaged through
the whole thing and it feels unfair to
say it out loud but it did have that
impact to me so I think it's also fair
to say that it's very understandable
that people had that reaction and and
you can see in Game of Thrones oh also I
think there's something interesting this
is just my limited perspective into it
but there's something interesting about
movies TV shows even games when they're
based on books there's certain kind of
firm complex novelty that is felt in the
air like when you kind of see it like
when there's a movie based on a book
there's this kind of a sense of a layer
beneath it all that some
pekes true it that you don't necessary
and in movies that I'm being directly
written into like the stories created
just for the movie and I can feel that
as well like when you when you watch
Game of Thrones season one kind of a
complexity of interaction to drama the
unsaid things right like that there are
things that are left unsaid and it's
left to the viewer to try to interpret
what what happened and and piece it
together and so on all of that novelty
was kind of nobody is the wrong word
it's more like this kind of restraint
and and choosing very carefully what to
tell at any given time that kind of just
disappeared to me like towards the end
everything became very expected and you
could already kind of see what's gonna
happen next of course the bad people
will you know get what they deserve and
and so on and and that's exactly kind of
what happened there is a TV show that
does a wonderful job from beginning to
end as is Breaking Bad which is the best
TV show on the planet yeah I think I
want to come to TV shows but I wanted to
get her perspective as well and before
we because I want to go into
recommendations after this for TV shows
because I know you have loads all of you
yeah Brooke what's your kind of take on
as someone who writes stories and has to
end them yeah well endings are very
tough and I think it's I can see exactly
why Sam you say that you have an inkling
of how the story is going to end because
often in the end is that here that final
stroke or that delivery of sort of forth
you know they saw this all has been
about perhaps or you know do you leave
with a question do you close it off do
you leave it open some of those things I
mean when I'm personally writing my
stories I have an indication of how it's
going to end but I don't necessarily
know what that looks like and so
sometimes in the rewriting I find what
I'm trying to say at the end and
actually when we were talking about
things just switching to Game of Thrones
that have had an impact on us that was
actually one thing I was going to
mention if we were going to stray from
games because I remember watching game
of
groans and I don't I don't really binge
TV much but that first season I just sat
there all day I remember just going this
is what TV can be like this is and I
think you know not it's the realness of
the characters like in the you know that
they actually are drawn very deeply in
the first couple of seasons as well and
I think perhaps what happens towards the
end is we that we have a lot going on
and there are a lot of characters we
need to catch up with and wind up and so
by nature of that we don't get to delve
into the details as much because there
are kind of fewer characters and less
going on in the earlier seasons too and
then the world opens up to us and I
don't personally think it's a it's a
great shame that when we go Game of
Thrones all we think about is the the
ending because it really did kind of
pave the way for a lot of other shows
that we have now I think just in terms
of being risque or the kind of dialogue
that you could have or the kind of I
don't know other I guess the level of
costumes the level of you know it was
incredible production and so it is you
know the ending is a very important part
of the story too so I can see both sides
of the argument but when I think about
that series I don't necessarily think
about how disappointing the ending was
it changed the way I look at TV really
yeah there's there's certainly a few
exceptions when it comes to endings of
things and I have like something I have
a tough time with because I acknowledge
that endings are very difficult and
especially when you have expectations of
viewers who have committed years of
falling along with certain stories of
certain characters it's the reason why
like for me personally when Twin Peaks
was going to come back I was very like
know like I was like no it was this
horrible like the beauty and it was the
the this open-ended thing it's like if
there's any way for that showed that I
could imagine for that show and is
without an ending and
anyways but the thing is the return I
ended up living the returned anyways as
a viewer but it's hard endings are
difficult and I think that's and I want
to I know I am on the move the
recommendations but there's also like a
part of it from a creative side of
things to diving into Sam what you said
like how you start with an ending which
seems to be everyone kind of has like
their different approach to writing
stuff like what do you think if it had
not ended if if the to last season's
wouldn't have happened if the show would
just you know in there would people be
more positive and excited about it and
and you know not giving them the ending
in in a show I I do wonder like yeah yes
yes they die I think they it would be a
legend as a TV show at this point for
sure at least to me they've never had an
ending yeah if you would erase those two
seasons then it would have been like
it's amazing when they run out of the
book content or they could wait 20 years
the show should be talking about returns
and because that was the perfect ending
our favorite endings but before we do
that I want to do another quick shout
out for the to fund raising causes that
we are raising money for one being black
lives matter you can see the link there
bit ly for first year - birla the other
one being covered relief efforts bit dal
way Forge - yes - covered and we got
another donation from Cole Henry who
donated towards black lives matter $25
thank you so much call remember any
amount helps if all the money goes
directly to
causes so it's super useful and super
beneficial so I'm gonna start with
Brooke what is one of your not to put
you on the spot but to put you on the
spot what would you say is and I ending
that really stuck with you and something
that you recommend perhaps seeing
checking out because you know it follows
through all the way we can we can come
back to you if you want maybe come back
to me that's immediately to mind is a TV
show that I recommend which is the
watchman and there's something to be
said for that show it knew that it
didn't need anymore seasons like people
were like will there be a second season
they're like no we're done the show and
that is the ending and you know there's
something to be said for knowing when to
end or knowing when to stop I guess and
I thought that TV show did really well
in terms of collecting a lot of the
ideas from the comic and modernizing
them I guess for a more modern audience
I guess for today the like a lot of Alan
Moore stuff is very inspiring to me
and this particular TV show I think
teach very well in capturing yeah a lot
of cool complexities I guess and
probably it's almost even more relevant
now to watch with that kind of thing but
I will also think of some other endings
yeah watch watchman's relevant enough
HBO to make it available for free for a
period yeah if you have a morning yeah
yeah watch it and but make sure what's
your what's your thing you said Breaking
Bad did you want to stick with Breaking
Bad urge on the switch no I changed my
mind
i I hate love endings that haunts me and
yeah I mentioned to return like you know
season three and twin pigs it definitely
stuck with me I will remember that the
ending for the rest of my life
Sopranos another interesting example it
kinda
haunts me still and and definitely like
you know the movie Space Odyssey as well
the the complexity of emotions that
rollercoaster do you go through trying
to understand what the hell is happening
and and your mind kind of racing and
paying attention to every single frame
every single sound trying to decipher
that's that's what i love i love endings
like that and it's kind of neatly
packaged here is when everybody goes
home i I feel a bit disappointed so yeah
so but Sopranos I think is something
that in a way it's almost still kind of
discussed and it was like a recent
article it was kind of revealed a bit
like what happened there and it was
actually a bit disappointing to me to
realize that they must distract that the
creator had on that but yeah III
anything that that haunt you I love Sam
is a specific ending that sticks out to
you or something that you really really
liked and would recommend people would
should check out see through yeah it's
it's interesting when when the ending
works really well and and and you look
back then then you see the whole and and
and and just feel that that was perfect
and and not necessarily specifically
think that the ending is is the thing I
mean obviously there are you know great
movies with with create endings like we
we talked about Fight Club that being
one I enjoyed usual suspects inception
you know interesting things left hanging
I do very much I mean I love David Lynch
overall I really really loved the third
season of Twin Peaks and loved the
structure with the two last episodes
that we are kind of you know the
audience is kind of in the in the not
the last one that but the previous one
the audience is even the t.t expected
ending and and then David Lynch does
David Lynch and and we
and open up a new story and and that
that is the proper ending so so create
wonderful Watchmen I I did enjoy the
whole show I thought that that was a
phenomenal achievement like you know
doing a sequel to a classic but many
thing to actually be both a prequel and
a sequel and adding meaningful content
that that you know sets it up in an
interesting way adds color to the
original thing and and then pulls off a
wonderful ending like even even they're
kind of the final picture without
spoiling anything and the choice of the
song with the lyrics that that suddenly
you know I am the ball rose and and you
know the lyrics pointing to certain
things that that we had as elements
building up towards the ending really
really great I actually like like
Lindelof like like as a creator is a
very interesting one and and I had not
like like mix you had actually raved
about earlier about the leftovers the
show and I I had missed it III I have to
watch man I did go and and watch the
leftovers and it's a it's a great show
as well very interesting one overall
yeah I feel about the ending yeah going
too far yeah I mean it's it was such a
big conceptual thing to do to give us
right there that that then when you stop
and start start like poking it it kind
of leaves leaves something to be desired
for but it didn't spoil anything to me I
the whole holding yeah Brooke did you
have anything another one else sometime
oh look I'm gonna be a bit cliche here
yeah it seems to me like everyone might
make this statement once or twice but
the ending to the novel 1984 was left me
cold like it was just like I was
devastated you know it is not a happy
ending at all but in and of itself it
really like it captures exactly
everything that is in that narrative I
guess and the reason I bring it up is
because I was reading Margaret Atwood's
essays on science fiction and how that's
influenced her work and what she thought
about it and she actually talked about
all well and Huxley and we like examined
how they approached dystopia and yeah
the ending in and it reminded me of the
ending to that book and I was like oh
yes like it was just yeah it stayed with
me so it was probably a bit of a classic
sort of book that people reach for I
guess for references and things but I
think cuz it did make an impact with its
ending yeah actually reminded me of the
book that we mentioned earlier the
three-body problem was like a series of
books and man the ending of that series
is really I can it I don't want to spoil
anything but it really really is an
ending in many different layers of
levels that was amazing to read and so
heartily recommend it to anybody who
likes science fiction very very kind of
a hard sci-fi was it the three-body
problem was that what was yeah that was
the first book and then it's actually a
series of books and by Chinese always or
was it his name it's a huge huge thing
yeah yeah but it deals with questions
about reality and universe to the extent
that you don't expect let's say it like
that wonderful wonderful experience -
really true and it's it's kind of
devastating at the end in many different
levels where you start to understand the
limits of universe and how long time can
go on and things like that and things
that haunt you it's brand yes I'm gonna
give - I'm about - it's it's it's won by
I experienced many times and every time
I recently I finished it and every time
I do it makes me feel warm and fuzzy
inside it's Avatar The Last Airbender I
don't know if you guys have seen that
show yeah it's the Nickelodeon show and
I think it's got one of the strongest
endings I think it's got with some of
the most like amazing character arcs in
fiction I've seen like and this kind of
goes back to recommending things and
wanting people to like things it's one I
always recommend to people and I can
never get them past the it's a
Nickelodeon Kids show and the first
season is kind of that like the first
season is very much that finger wagging
like you shouldn't steal because
stealing is bad message in each episode
but then like halfway through that first
Asian it takes a hard turn into really
heady and like mature subject matter and
like there's a character called Prince
Zuko who goes on just an incredible
character arc where he starts off being
this evil kind of kid on a mission to
hunt down the Lost Saviour of mankind
and over the course of experiencing kind
of the world it shifts who he is and
changes him and by the end of the series
he's in a completely different position
from where he started and it all
culminates in this ending that just
feels good and it feels right and it
feels
like a definitive uplifting end I love
that series and I always recommend it
and he's really mean to me many times
yeah I've seen the show absolutely love
Last Airbender as well and to Coast Park
is and that's what's great it's not
something that kind of you know like
there's a big moment and then
everything's different it's not like
that at all it's really well crafted
through our three seasons and and the
ending is powerful also because the the
avatar is is is a very human being in
many different ways and and struggles
with issues that I would expect any
human being to struggle with is not
Marvel superhero by any means he's
afraid nervous like will he be good
enough
should he and there's this moment where
he kind of thinks about like you know
trying to reach that but history of
leaving you know the world behind or
detaches are from from change because
change causes suffering right there's
this Sun Buddhistic thinking right and
and it's a big moment in the story and
it has a lot of complicated emotional
kind of a glimpses into human life that
you would never ever expect from yeah
when you see a Nickelodeon show that's
not you don't make that connection at
all so I was really delighted when I was
actually heard about the show from a
writer clay and promised promised to
watch it and I'm really glad that
recommended seeker this is this is I've
recommended I what occurred many times
and he's always been like now you heard
such true that's what really Glicker
we're trying to like be like we want
what I wanted to watch it with him and
in this this all this happened and now I
feel like a true he's watching it
without me that's fine but now I feel
like I strange like it just wouldn't
feel right I'm also like very wrapped up
and many many books and games and things
I'm trying to like put book market you
know trying to put I'm making up excuses
I know I am
I know that Kurt's got a few questions
that he wants to ask you but before we
kind of launch into that just quick
reminder for folks that we are raising
money for black lives matter and kovat
relief efforts in partnership with
Derrick relief you can see both links on
the screen
Bly for first years - BLM for black
lives matter and - Cove aid for covert
relief efforts please donate if you can
cut it's over to you I have lots of
questions about creativity I have a I
mean as someone who has like my own
rituals and routines and such I and then
in the room with many people who am i
for a different creative reasons one
thing that I'm curious about is kind of
that maybe meditation what it takes to
create or see the direction of something
is it a cup of coffee is it is it like a
zit the routine there's like this one
quote I remember it's like in order to
get in there you are I already finished
mine off right before this started
there's one um but you know I always
like thinking about this one concept of
in order to get one hour of painting in
you need three hours of preparation for
it and that's always like one thing
that's ways in the back of my mind I was
curious if there was a telling thing
that happened before you guys went into
the kritis fear I mean you just
magically sit down and happens do you
have the magical ones I guess I kind of
thought I mean there's a lot of putting
things up and writing notes and so on
and unto me early on it sounds more like
this really detached separate conceptual
thoughts that I recognized there's
something there but I don't know yet how
to use that and what I need to do is
walk and I think many people in the
office see me just walking around
sometimes I think I wonder like what the
hell is he doing but I just walk yes
and it's me it's me processing it's me
kind of I've noticed that that's what
happens to me I need to go and walk and
then there's
we bang into subconscious that gets
triggered where things start to click
into place and there's there's a lot of
work that needs to exist before that but
I can sometimes see how they're the to
be able to create those connections I
need to somehow engage in to some other
activity to let the subconscious kind
kind of like do its thing
but I constantly recognize a connection
but there's possibly something there but
it doesn't quite click and that's the
kind of ritual I I often do and I do it
every day and it's just something that
is crucial and necessary for the process
for me at least
yeah I have my fair share of pacing
certainly just like walking back and
forth and trying to do that see I'm
sorry I didn't cut you off I was gonna
throw it to Brooke and see what she's
got and then Sam see what funnily enough
yes well when I'm writing my own fiction
or coming up with a design for a game or
thinking about how that's going to play
out sometimes I do get up and walk from
my desk and go back again I do that more
at home now because no one can see me
walking around like a fool
but I also do like to see like for my
personal writing I sit down with a cup
of coffee and write which is one of the
first things I do but I will write a
journal first which is to empty my brain
of things and on my mind so I will write
about I have to go shopping today and
get food and remember to do this and you
know this is what I did yesterday and
then I will write some some fiction or
for some times it's about finding
references or finding something that
inspires me or helps me see your
direction sometimes it's like looking at
how some other games have done some
things and then thinking about if that
would suit for the problem that I'm
trying to solve so there's a couple of
different ways into it I think and it's
about finding that flow I guess
when you're writing fiction for me it's
about being able to see what I'm writing
like being able to see the scene and
then for for a design or for a narrative
design it's almost sort of a slightly
different section of my brain that's a
little bit more and if I was interacting
with this story what would I want to do
and you know how would I like to do it
and can we do it in different ways and
then yeah looking at that so there are
some initial thoughts Sam do you have
any rituals hmm deadlines are very
helpful wonderful and and horrible I I
think that you know creating stories
writing it is both wonderful and
horrible at the same time and it's it's
it's a weird thing how it can be that it
always ends up being that at different
phases of the project you are working on
sometimes it's it's so wonderful that
kind of nothing compares to it and and
sometimes it's it's it's so variable
that that you forget that it's wonderful
and and you know no matter how many
times you go through a full story it's
always that and and yes deadlines are
create they create a lot of anxiety but
they also move things forward and and
then you always can iterate even if it
sucks but at least you control all thing
whiteboards whiteboards are you know
especially a bigger more complex thing
that you can break it down on certain
detail level and and then just take two
steps back and you see the whole thing
it helps a lot its I love it
I learned that from you Sam hi I
purposely Bordetella thank you I
obviously bought a whiteboard and put it
up in my room so that I could work on
story ideas and
all kinds of things because I've seen
you riding on there like sometimes
upward of three white boards in Sam's
office at any one time doing and also
when we worked together you've always
been at the white board writing and I
can see why it's so useful because you
can lay everything out and see it your
mind method essentially and yes but you
know you can fit a lot of text into a
white board yes at home I unfortunately
had to wipe it clean and century for
this now I'm disappointed I was kind of
excited too but yeah I mean it's it's
it's also its mind is a wonderful thing
and and I'm I'm always surprised and it
in in a way it feels almost like she's
cheating that that when when you are
working on a story and you have a
problem and and I I didn't come up with
this I I read it somewhere someone wiser
than me you know
just the idea of resting your thoughts
against it and and not pushing too hard
but just keeping it present and and your
mind will come up with a solution even
if you are not actively you know making
it happen
it just happens at certain point and
sometimes you kind of lose faith in that
happening and and it takes a while but
then it always has happened I like you
know on fictional level we we might talk
about in in you know a certain
ten-year-old game about the writer's
block and then about it but it's a you
know it's it's not really in my
experience not that because it always
solves itself at some point it might be
torture for a while but then suddenly
you know an answer purchase from them
yeah I was gonna say like I recently
went through this and it helped me kind
of reach a realization about my
situation like it's not writing on a
level that any of you guys are writing
but I realized the other day or a few
months ago actually that every video
game review I've ever written was in one
room oh you told me about this yeah it
was like and over the course of my
entire career of writing about games
every review I did I always wrote at
home in this one room and I almost like
iterated on that space until it was the
perfect writing space for me but I just
never was conscious of the fact that I
was doing that and I was crafting this
thing and I wasn't aware of what I
wasn't aware of the tie between my
creative output and my ability to write
and that space until I moved to a
different part of the world I'm in San
Francisco now the room was in London and
my first review assignment for when I
moved over was Final Fantasy 7 remake
and I sat down to review one of the most
like eagerly anticipated games of all
time and my brain suddenly went this is
all wrong like you can't write here you
need to be in a specific place and
that's when I realized oh no I'm in
trouble and I've had to start like
figuring the mental like part of
detaching that place and creating a new
kind of hub for me to write reviews in I
guess to I guess to draw into some sort
of questions and what is the deal with
your weird basement room that you seem
to write in like ways that you picture
of that is terrifying well I was bad
though as brilliant things really
inspiring see working at home I mean I'm
used to working off-site because like at
least for me certain times in a project
when when when you need to focus on on
creating the story or writing certain
kinds of screenplays
I do need to be alone it's it's very
hard to focus
enough to be able to get in and process
it and progress further so so working
off-site is is is a common thing that
I'm used to what ended up as a challenge
being home and the whole family with
kids being at home and then finding you
know peace and quiet enough to be to be
able to work so so we have a few rooms
here and finding the different spaces I
I've been the best thing and at that
room which which I ended up making
public is in the garage and and that
being actually stepping out and going
through a door and closing that door
that is finally the best place in my
home where when nobody is gonna bother
me and so and and yes it is pretty
pretty how should I say crew that
doesn't matter like like you know here
I'm I'm in the basement that here I
actually have a whiteboard which is
great as well and and views but but game
consoles are also in this room so you
know with the hall in this space is not
an alone space for me all the time and
it's a true if I can brighten anywhere
basically like throw him in a dungeon
he'll just figure it out his skills are
he can write anywhere and complete all
the my behind it no weapons like we've
got just under five minutes left and
before we kind of wrap this up I want to
take the opportunity if you just let you
guys talk about what you're enjoying
right now and what you what is kind of
exciting you either something that's
available now it could be anything a
book
movie TV show music album wherever it
could be it could be something on the
way what what is exciting you let's
start with mixing and go to Brooklyn and
Sam I kind of already mentioned things
I'm into I mean last of us is is you
know I was very excited about the game
already before and the first game to me
is one of the most experienced messing
experience created so you know it was
clear to me that the the sequel is going
to be something special especially when
I saw the first images I know that
there's this reaction to the game that
I'm seeing where people see that the
borough violent world and unrightfully
react in and kind of horror to towards
all of that and and and to me is it's a
it's a demonstration of so no kind of a
singular conviction that they have in in
what they set out to create that they
knew they knew that people will see this
game in a certain kind of light and
instead of compromising it they stuck
with it and went all the way and I think
that's what art should be that's what
creativity should be and and of course
there's there's a limit there somewhere
of course which which you have the gauge
and understand but but they went all the
way and I'm so happy that they did yes
it's a very tough emotional experience
to play through that game but and and it
was an interesting one when Brooke
mentioned for instance hands myself that
it's not necessarily a kind of thing
that is comfortable wash it's very tough
and I do feel like Last of Us deals with
certain kind of a basic elements
regarding human condition that are that
that affects you as as you kind of go
through it and it sounds weird for me to
say that it's a certainly recommended to
everybody maybe not okay there's a maybe
not for you know if you're under 18 and
so on still very much an amazing
experience is something that I'm very
much into and I'm happy to exist and
enjoying thoroughly
awesome Brooke
well I'm currently playing the last of
us - at the moment as well
but before that I played the Lost Legacy
which has been out for a while now but
if someone wants an intro into Naughty
Dog games and has not experienced their
games before this one's quite nice
because even though it's a spinoff it's
of the Uncharted series it's it's
shorter and I would say like a like
quite a digestible goods witty dialogue
very funny very enjoyable game and I'm I
wrote I wrote down a list of things I'm
so looking forward to and I will just
disappear no one will find me when
vampire the masquerade bloodlines -
comes out like I will be gone
mixer or he knows and Sam I talked about
the first one constantly much to the
frustration of everyone but um it kind
of blew my mind and I actually avoided
mentioning it at the start but I'm
looking forward to number two and I'm
reading some Margaret Atwood short
stories which are just lovely and funny
so that's what I'm doing currently
I will hold hardly back vampire
recommendation Sam what you what's
what's exciting you right now summer
vacation is just around the corner and
there is such a huge backlog of
everything waiting so you know a pile of
books maybe maybe you know I mean last
was definitely looking forward to diving
in and experiencing that maybe maybe
maybe kind of out of the big pile of
books waiting to be read and this is by
the way something that I've been I mean
I love to read but I'd find that with
with kind of being busy and at work it's
it's getting hard for me too
Casey Nobles as as fast as I used to so
I kind of put a lot of expectation on
reading pleasure for for summer vacation
more and more empty on Harrison's new
one called sunken land begins to rise of
my wedding list that I want to read
first but a lot of other foods as well a
lot of lot of shows lot of movies games
too many you know make a proper dent in
these backlogs I'm one of those people
that even if I find myself not having as
much time safe for reading I still keep
buying books just as fast as I used to
when something gets my attention I do
buy it which gets you to the interesting
problem or putting putting the books
that you have read into cardboard boxes
and storing them and more and more your
bookshelf is filled with books that you
actually have not read Oh sadly we've
come to know before we head out I think
I can speak for both Kerr and myself
when we recommend you everyone checks
our control yes that's so that's not
something like like I said earlier like
we're not here to plug anything but I
know that GameSpot Kurt myself there's
various people on the team that love
control and you guys did an amazing job
on it so I'd recommend anyone who hasn't
played it check that out once you're
done with the Last of Us and I meantime
thank you all so much for joining us
it's been an absolutely fascinating
conversation I've got a long list of
things to check out of course any time
you're welcome to do two games for any
time and but yeah well the folks
watching please keep it locked on daily
charity streams tomorrow we're gonna
have the last podcast on the left crew
playing contradiction we're going to
test their ability to snuff out liars
and in the meantime you can check out
the links below for black lives matter
and colvett relief efforts we're gonna
be going until mid July I think so
there's plenty more charity streams
coming and we'll see you then
thank you so much Ron thank you folks
[Music]